皆さんこんにちは同源ですと今日は外国人がよく間違える日本語そしてまあ
外国人だったらこれはしておいた方がいいという日本の文化について話をしてみたいと
思います
クリチは
本当にビックリして
びっくりしたけどメリしてるヌ今
日本語のミスト日本文化について話をしています
あっそうですかはい
じゃなんで靴はエテルノリス丁寧なので一番目は1番目は敬語です
聞い語難しいですねめっちゃ難しいで
難しいですやめてやめてください
やめろ
ギャ目なさいティがどこから来たの
$ウェイノーやっそう聞いてるんじゃなくて
no a それいいこの厚んじゃないか今の老害って言ったから
a 袖口がよノルウェーじゃなくて塗るウェイです
日本語のミスはもういい日本の文化についてるん
まずは電車の乗り方編みが気分か退け戦勇まずはお寿司の食べ方について話をします
お箸を使って食べる人が多いんですけれども実は直接手を使ったけど9サーモンがす
きーろー米ちゃんだけどねおらず発音について話をしたいと思います
発音と
いいますとこうら行は難しいとかっていう外国人が多いんですけれども
その殻を取っていうよりもアクセントのほうが難しいけどスター日本語にはアクセント
のパターンが4つあります
頭だか中高をだかそして平板
まあ外国人だったら一番難しい
あるー
今彼がサーモンを食べますまあですから日本語を話す時お子
日本苦じゃなくて日本語です
日本
ほんとだ
こんなに沢山のミスを犯すとに阻止増えた本当にビックリして
ほんとびっくんっ
ni
た